[Music]
[Music]
mmm
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler
and today we're talking about the big
topic of free speech but we're going to
put a different spin on it instead of
talking
so much about rights we're going to try
to reframe it in terms of
responsibilities
the consequences of one's actions
even though you have a right to do them
does not
uh remove the uh the consequences of
them
yeah and and we we could talk about how
to be a good speaker in
in the sense of being somebody who
actually deserves to to be heard you
know i think there's a lot of people in
the
free speech discussions that want to
insist on
oh i have to have a platform i have to
be heard
and they talk all the time about their
their right and that's important
but a lot of the stuff that gets said
under the rubric of free speech
isn't particularly worth you know
saying or hearing or it's just
mean-spirited or
or in bad faith and and so i think it
makes sense
for us at least at one point in time
and maybe this is that point in time to
focus instead a little bit more on being
a responsible speaker meaning somebody
who
is accountable not just in the sense of
like people you know booing you or
yaying you but
something that that involves more of the
the person
in uh the speech that we we we use and
so i think this is
personally i think this is an important
topic and quite overlooked
i guess it's not quite one-to-one but
kind of the idea
of you know uh being a responsible
driver and that
you have a yeah yeah
uh it's not quite a right but you you
have the the privilege
of driving it's endless but you know
there's certain
expectations while you do this um maybe
you know
we go to um uh was a life liberty and
property for john locke that uh just
because you have
uh life doesn't mean that you have
the ability to do anything with your
life there are certain other rights that
people
outside of you have that you can
infringe upon
yeah i mean that's sort of a libertarian
perspective that says that what matters
most
are rights and that you know your rights
end where another person's
rights begin and they will talk about
them they often tend to be kind of
thin in terms of how they they conceive
of uh
the social fabric i would go further
actually i'll bring up two things so so
thomas hobbs who
you know locke and and all the other
people who
take after him uh uses sort of a um
you know a nemesis you could say even
thomas hobbes in
talking about what's required within the
social contract he says
one of the the laws of nature is that
everybody
basically adapt themselves to everybody
else and he uses the metaphor
of how a stone that doesn't fit into the
fence because it's
got the wrong sort of corners it's going
to get thrown out you know
and and i think that this is something
that often gets left out when we're
talking about
speech maybe because if i go to your
house and i like
knock you know i'm doing something
that's uh destructive to your property
it's really easy to tell but when we're
when we're
transgressing certain norms when it
comes to
how we use speech even though we can do
it there's a lot of cases where we
probably
shouldn't do it and i and i do want to
say too that i i don't want to frame
this just in terms of thou
shalt not you know in terms of negative
norms
and say well we should restrict free
speech a lot more
i want to talk about what would be
positive
in being a good speaker in in being the
kind of speaker
who engages with other people
in positive ways yeah they
we are like at base a very social sp
species and thus there are lots of
benefits that we have derived
from being able to work within and
with the group in order to achieve ends
and if you can't speak well and
uh get people i guess on your side if
that's the best way to frame that
then you're not going to actually
achieve your ends and so
this might be a utilitarian argument of
like what do you actually want to do
yeah i would say you could also have bad
ends of course right so we could say
ah let's all do hate speech against so
and so and we coordinate together
and bully somebody so not not all ends
are necessarily
good ends just by being ends but you're
right you you know augustine points this
out
you need some sort of what he calls
concord or peace
even in a band of robbers they can't all
be
just doing their own thing and robbing
each other they have to have some sort
of coordination
and if we want a better life if we want
something that goes just beyond
you know looking at each other from
across our walls
arm to the teeth in a hobbesian way or
something along those lines
if we want a true human life together we
have to be able to communicate in ways
that
allow us to connect as persons to
express who we are
what we're interested in what we value
and there does have to be you know a
capacity for saying no i think you've
got things wrong
but disagreement doesn't always have to
be done in in
you know such in your face devil's
advocate kind of
jerkish ways that the people who are
often defending free speech
see some some almost like value in they
they seem to think that
uh either you know we have to tolerate
this sort of thing because it's
important for some reason or another
we'll get into some of those those ideas
like with the marketplace of ideas and
those sort of tropes or they're like
listen it's my rights and i get to
express myself no matter how
noxious and you know poorly formed my
my sentiments or conscience or whatever
it happens to be
are so i think we want to think about
where we want to move towards what what
kind of things we want to emulate what
kind of people we want to
promote rather than just
saying well so long as you don't break
the law so long as you don't violate
these
really you know thin norms you're you're
a-okay
kind of like remember it reminds me of i
don't know half of the episodes of
seinfeld
which are someone commits some sort of
social faux pas
and so that sets off a a you know rube
goldberg uh series of events that
results in
you know the the nothing that that show
is about
yeah and and curb your enthusiasm is
just sort of a follow-up of that right
and maybe an intensification of that
um yeah and and they have conflicts too
about
whether a norm exists whether it's been
violated
whose fault it is they they they get
into all of these really
extensive discussions about those sorts
of things
and and some of the thing earlier
talking about
remind me of the you know access
and and who who gets access and yeah um
who um you know just by dent
of their uh who they
are their their background their uh you
know
wealth their you know reputation or just
like maybe even more basic like
how they look they dress yeah um a lot
of times will
prevent them from even being taken
seriously at the very
onset and if you are
automatically uh dissing someone's
or uh discarding someone's opinion uh
based on those things then there's also
a
lack of speech and the reciprocity that
is expected in that
yeah and you can say the on the flip
side that something similar
also happens where some people
just by virtue of you know whose kids
they are or
being you know particularly good looking
or
saying the right thing at the right time
to appeal to a broad audience
or we could go out on the line they get
to talk and everyone else
basically gets pushed out you know this
is not something that we like prepared
in the show notes but
um there's talk about like an attention
economy right
just like there's a a monetary economy
and all sorts of other economies
and i think that that's that's quite
true there's only so much
room on the stage and there's only so
much time
you know if you think about this show
the more we talk about one thing the
less we can talk about another thing so
we're always
as let's call it consumers of attention
making some decisions about who's worth
watching and who's who's
not worth watching or listening to or
who gets to speak
and um you know quite often
the the decisions that are made about
that are quite arbitrary and unfair i
would say
mention you know like the old adage it
bleeds it leads you know the idea that
you know
negative things and things are true
fearful are
one of our really big biases and oh i
think we spoke about it
a couple weeks ago talking about i can't
remember exactly the author of the study
the conclusion of the study was that um
on average we're about four times more
aware of negative things than that we
are positive things
and so it's it holds our attention as
well as
it remains within our ability to
recollect
um significantly longer and so if you
are
just out there to try to you know
push that like mental trigger of our
biases are just built into the way that
we perceive the world
or exploit some some issue that's arisen
that's controversial and say
hey those people over there are terrible
you know let's let's focus on that
right yeah and then so it it swallows up
it's like a black hole of
attention whereas there could be a lot
you know
when we're talking about like rational
debate that's you know rather benign
but if you have like you know uh a riot
or something and everyone's like
yes and ignore the thing that's
happening over here you know something
like that was happening
i i don't think a lot of people actually
watch tv news anymore
at given times of the night but i
remember
back when we used to do that the bigger
city you were in the more it would be
dominated by
crime stories because obviously there
was more crime so like in a city like
chicago
there could be like a murder or a
shooting each day
and then people would get the idea that
oh it's so much more unsafe here than it
is in appleton wisconsin
and appleton could be you know depending
on on you know when we're talking about
it might be more dangerous than chicago
less dangerous than chicago you know you
could
you can look at the stats uh for that
sort of thing but
because the tv um news
cycle worked the way that it would you
would get a lot more of that
and and that would draw your attention
and
also chicago has a lot more news
stations than appleton does and so if
you want to compete and
draw the viewers well there's that too
yeah
yeah we could hope we could talk i mean
we could actually do like a whole show
on the attention economy
sometime perhaps but yeah but let's come
so maybe let's go back to speech
yeah yeah yeah so i think that typically
and i might be wrong about this so it's
not like i've done some sort of
scientific survey of this but i think
that
most of the time that people are talking
about freedom of speech
they're framing it in one of
two main ways or they're framing it in
another way that's that's
even less productive so
one of the really common ways is to
frame it in terms of rights and rules to
say okay
there are certain rules you can't cross
these and anything else
it's your right you can say whatever you
like and then you know that that's not
going to work for reasons that we'll
we'll talk about it leads to all sorts
of crazy paradoxes and leads to
conflicts
but the other way that that jon stewart
mill
is probably the the most famous
proponent of
is to say that there's a kind of social
utility there's a usefulness a greater
benefits
over harms in allowing as much freedom
of speech as
possible and not censoring or punishing
or however you want to frame it
um so there's there's sort of like a
deontological approach that's
focused on rights and rules and then
there's a utilitarian
approach that says well people might say
really terrible things but overall it
works out to everybody's benefit if we
we allow this sort of thing even though
it can be you know hurtful to some
people
and then i would say in an extension to
mill
like on liberty he is defending the
freedom of thought
of discussion but it is in the
collective pursuit
of truth it's not uh
freedom of thought and discussion for
its own sake but it has to have some
you know ends of the pursuit of truth
yeah and that's something that i think a
lot of
free speech advocates sometimes
they give lip service to that they're
like well you know marketplace of ideas
it's going to work out better for all of
us
and then they say horrible things and
you're like i'm not sure that's really
advancing the discussion here you know
or you could say like well how many
times do you have to like
spout nazi propaganda for us to actually
have
gotten the message that maybe this is
one one thing we need to engage with
you know um so yeah
the the use of mill is quite often
itself disingenuous i i would say
right i would say so you're saying oh go
ahead
i said you were saying i think that in
addition to these two more
principled approaches there's also some
people who are just quite selfish about
it and they invoke
freedom of speech just so they can do
whatever they they want to
or say whatever they want to rather um
so you know we call that just sort of a
plain egoist
approach to it and you know these are
usually the bad actors
in it and i do want to say one thing
though
a person could be a bad actor at one
point in time
and then maybe they they get older and
they start realizing that
the way that they're doing things is is
hurting people and they
they change their views about it and try
to make amends and
and you know so we don't want to like
condemn somebody once and for all for
their
terrible uses of freedom of of speech
when especially when they're they're you
know younger but but we do have to hold
people accountable and
i think this is where the paradoxes
start to arise because
people who say oh freedom of speech
means i get to say whatever i want
they they often don't want to accept the
consequences
that come with it which means everybody
else gets to say whatever they want
which could include hey buddy you're a
jerk and we don't want to spend time
with you
you know right suddenly then oh you're
not respecting my freedom of speech
you're censoring me
but that's equally freedom of speech
right what were you saying yeah
you mad bro yeah yeah yeah
uh that's probably one of the most
common techniques i've i've actually
seen too like in youtube comments and
twitter feuds and stuff like that is to
accuse the other person of being
emotional
and responding you know say an anger
right
you're you're only you know you're being
mean to me you're condemning my speech
act
uh because it hit some button usually
you can throw in like calling somebody a
snowflake or
some other slogan about facts and
feelings but really one is
typically you know cross some sort of
line and
and even if somebody is angry it doesn't
matter if they're if they're rightly
condemning what it is that you
you spouted out you know right
so surprisingly i had one of those
experiences not too long ago
and it wasn't even online it wasn't like
veil of ignorance or that veil of
anonymity
anonymity yeah what happened
um i don't need to go into
too dif too much but it was just a an
argument of asserting that other people
were
uh emotional on wow
the other person was perfectly logical
yeah at least significantly more uh
even keel than the other person that was
uh making the assertion in the first
place
okay uh so there's definitely a little
bit of
projection there yeah i mean
that that's so let's think about this in
in sort of free speech terms i don't
think that we want to like have some
sort of universal norm where you can't
point
out to other people hey you're being
emotional and that's affecting
the conversation between us and if
you're going to talk to me in that way
maybe i won't talk to you right now you
know maybe i'll wait till you calm down
and we can approach this we don't have
to like buy into like the you know pure
logic reason
fact sort of sort of ideology that's out
there that some people seem to have
and and those are those are people who
are never like in very close contact
with any three of those
those things uh even though they use
none of us are spock
yeah exactly and we wouldn't want to be
you know um
but i i think that it's it's a perfectly
valid
use of one's uh freedom of speech to say
i'm i'm not gonna
talk with you i mean this is what mill
calls the social sanction
he he thinks that you know maybe
everybody
should have the capacity to say what's
on their mind but then you can like turn
your back on them if you want to
you don't have to engage with them i
think that a lot of people
who insist on how important freedom of
speech is
they're not just demanding the right to
say something and say it once they're
demanding the right to say it
over and over and over again they're
demanding
acknowledgement and recognition from
other people who
don't agree with them and they're trying
to get something more than
let's let's say it like this they're
trying to get something more than they
deserve on the face of it
under the rubric of free speech
what do you think about that idea does
that conform to our experience or
am i off on this or as i feel like yes
there's like an
expectation that they should be able to
say anything
you know without any consequences and
uh yeah and and maintain good standing a
good reputation within
the group i guess that you're in and
it's a lot easier for you to
uh be in places in which reputation
doesn't matter if you can be
in anonymous places you know 4chan or
reddit or whatever yeah
or even twitter if you you want to be
getting new handles all the time
that uh oh man that like really aged me
handles
um yeah i haven't heard anyone talk
about a twitter handle for quite a while
i forgot about that
breaker breaker um and um
you know there's there's definitely like
that once again that social aspect that
if you're you're in a group and someone
is constantly like if you're in your
friends group and one guy is
constantly like uh breaking the social
norms within that
that group eventually he's just not
gonna get invited out anymore
and because he's you know kind of
abusing his position
and he's losing that reputation the
entire time and
and there's that that loss there uh yeah
if you have
anonymity then you can just keep on you
know poking buttons and slinging turds
or wherever you need to go yeah
well that's that's actually a good set
of points i think
that um
you know again mill calls this the
social sanction there's all sorts of
ways of
of thinking about this we could ask well
is that
a a use of of freedom of speech that
um just has to be respected just as much
so it so if i
am on twitter and somebody says
something that's overtly racist and i
say
wow you're you know you're saying
something that's really awful maybe we
should
boycott you right they call this cancel
culture now right
um am i transgressing am i going too
far in in doing that or is that a
legitimate use of
freedom of speech i think that that if
we're going to like open up the gates
and say well
we're going to be very uh permissive
then you gotta accept that just as much
as as somebody
being quite offensive yeah i guess
i would i'd be
i would like to to break down cancel
culture because there's definitely a
portion of cancer culture that you could
definitely call
just a straight boycott and then there
is a little bit of that dog pile
which is not quite exactly a
boycott in the traditional sense of the
boycott and i think that that well
dogpile is just calling people bad stuff
back to them right it doesn't have
consequences outside of say twitter
if if if you um decide to get all your
twitter buddies to dog pile me
there aren't any any i mean i feel bad
right so you hurt my feelings and all
that but there aren't any real world
consequences
outside of that you're not you're not
hurting my there are s
there are some like okay i'm taking
extreme cases obviously
and so there was uh the woman i believe
she made some joke i can't remember what
the joke was
oh the one who flew to racist right yeah
yeah and then
and then was lost her job by the time
that she got off the plane
in that case though i don't i mean i
don't think you can say it's the dog
pile that
that well i i don't know i mean
the employer fires her made it more
aware that
people that was aware like you unless
her employer was
specifically watching her twitter and
like going like
well should i be you know looking at all
my employees and make sure that none of
them ever say anything that
like might be a little untoward yeah
and i guess it feels like sometimes
the uh response is greater than
the infraction
originally done it's like uh
yes well that i mean that's interesting
i i would say that
any sort of um
if we want to call it justice in the
sense of uh
people getting payback or getting
getting remotely what they deserve
it's always going to be pretty crude
right it's not
when it when it's something like people
piling in on twitter
or on i don't know facebook or some
something else in social media
i don't think you're going to get an
exact punishment fits the crime sort of
thing going on
and we can also think too like so let's
say somebody's
been saying a whole bunch of egregious
things over time
should you like have exactly that number
of tweets going at them saying you're a
jerk you're a jerk and
and maybe being racist is more hurtful
than just calling somebody out on their
racism although
from what a lot of racists say it seems
to be very painful to be called a racist
oh no you know well i think it's i think
it's very painful
lily here yeah it's probably more
painful for people who
don't deserve it than people who do
deserve it but people who do deserve it
quite visibly
get very upset when you when you call
them out on it or they or they say yes i
am and and they try to justify it but
here's the point
there's also like a oh go ahead uh uh
it's the the like the difference between
like
you know the idea being racist is really
bad and everyone seems to agree upon
that
and then like there's the idea that as
long as i'm not like overtly saying
specifically racist things
yeah or like saying things that they
might not
explicitly know um is
racist but is definitely racist and
someone calls them out on that then they
get really offended because they're like
i'm a good person and you're saying that
i do something that only a bad person
says
instead of trying to kind of remove them
from whatever the perception you are is
like i did an action
my action doesn't always make me i have
the ability to
uh learn from that action um and that
that seems to be
one instance where people get really
offended because
they don't realize the damage they're
doing
yeah that that is quite true i mean i
think you can generalize that
um about people engaging in
in anything that's transgressing some
some norm that they they probably should
know about but don't know about right
so if i i don't know
you know when i was a kid you might be
able to relate to this too
um there's a lot of debate about whether
you should ever spank your kids
and you know the psychological data
seems to be saying it's probably a bad
idea
to do that you know but i grew up on a
street where
um there were very few kids who weren't
spanked at all they just got time-outs
or
alternative punishments and then there
were a vast majority of us who did get
spanked and then there were kids who got
beaten and and you could kind of tell
the difference between
some people would say oh it's all
illegitimate use of force but we we
would say no i mean that over there is
definitely illegitimate
this over here i don't like it but i
kind of had it coming to me and i
learned
my lesson and i'm not going to do that
anymore you know and then there were
some borderline cases of course
and and some of the people who were not
using cor you know corporal punishment
might be
just as terrible and abusive just in
other ways emotionally abusive verbally
abusive anyway um
what was the point i was trying to make
with this we're trying to like
find uh degrees yeah and so
you know if we think about somebody now
in the present who
realizes that they shouldn't have
spanked their kids
right they
they might have been in a position where
it's harder for them to
grasp that back then it was still if it
was wrong it was wrong
right and so we can sort of
retroactively read that and that's
that's why we feel things like remorse
and we grow as people and we
say holy you know i i was doing this
thing before and i shouldn't have been
doing that right
that's almost part of the maturation
process i think for most of us i know
i've got plenty of stuff where i
i did you know and said bone-headed
things um
that uh i'm happy i don't do anymore
you know yeah i i absolutely agree i you
know
a number of things especially things
that like would
trigger my anger and whatnot that i i
made sure
not to do and you know getting those out
of my regulation of actions is
a big boon to my overall well-being
yeah that's that's
and the well-being of those people that
i love and to live with
or even have to work with yeah i mean
anger in the workplace can be a big
problem i i i think you wanted to talk
about the
um paradox of tolerance right as
an issue in free speech so why don't you
lead us through
that so uh karl popper in the
early 20th century wrote the open
society in its enemies and he's
talking about this idea of the paradox
of tolerance
and so it goes forth unlimited tolerance
must lead
to the disappearance of tolerance if we
extend
unlimited tolerance even to those who
are intolerant
if we are not prepared to defend a
tolerant society against the onslaught
of the intolerant then the intolerant
will be destroyed
and intolerance with them in this
formation i do not imply for instance
that we should always suppress
the utterance of intolerant philosophies
as long as we can counter them
by rational argument and keep them in
check by public opinion
suppression would certainly be most
unwise
but we should claim the right to
suppress if necessary
even by force for it may easily turn out
that they are not prepared to meet us on
the level of rational argument
but begin by denouncing all arguments
they may forbid their followers to
listen to rational arguments
because it is deceptive and teach them
to
answer arguments by the use of their
fists
and pistols thus we should therefore
claim in the name of tolerance the right
to not
tolerate the intolerant yeah and so
there is a kind of paradoxicality to
this right you know intolerance
tolerance where do they
begin where do they end you know you're
being
intolerant to the to the the intolerant
how are you possibly tolerant yourself
yeah
so for example like if you take uh a
white supremacist that wants
the destruction of a portion of the
populace
if you are that portion of the paul that
populist or if you care about any of
that portion of the populace
there's no way you can tolerate that
idea that is calling for
the death uh or naming or or
you know any other relocation or
whatever yeah grievous harm done to
these people that is an
intolerant position that cannot be
tolerated in general discourse
yeah and i think that you could extend
this
i mean popper has some pretty extreme
stuff in mind right
but i think you could extend this to
people who just are not going
to carry out argument in good faith you
know
by the way that they behave that they've
got a position and they're only
interested in advancing that position
everything that they're saying is
essentially
propaganda or polemics you know
i i don't think that you have to give
them the same
mouthpiece or podium
as people who are in fact contributing
to
if there really is a marketplace of
ideas those would be bad actors within
the marketplace of ideas you know
they're trying to make the difference
between like an honest interlocutor and
a sophist
yeah and and you know it's not as if the
honest interlocutor
is going to be some sort of
communicative saint
right where they never ever ever say
something
out of anger and go a little bit too far
and call somebody a mean name or
something like that or cut them off or
whatever but i think we can we can say
there's a spectrum
and maybe you know once you reach a
certain point on the spectrum
somebody should make you sit down and
shut up you know
and so like
the example i use from like recent
history is
uh miley annopolis who over and over and
over again
showed that he wasn't interested in
actually having on this debate
he was just there to get people angry
yeah
stir stuff up right yeah and so there's
there's no point
after a while because that that was his
entire shtick
um that there's no reason for you to
even be
talking to this person because there's
nothing that you're going to be gaining
from this
let me let me give you a sort of uh a
thought experiment
um having to do with these free speech
issues
and see what you think of it and i'd be
interested you know if people want to
comment what what they have to think
about it as well
so imagine that there's somebody who
just always says the same thing they've
always got the same shtick
right and you've heard it already before
do you
is you know do you owe them letting them
say the same
thing one more time or can you is it
okay for you to say listen buddy i've
already heard your thing i've already
rejected it
you don't get to take up more space in
my head or time on my
my uh whatever my show or or stuff like
that
that that's so there's that scenario now
what if you
what if you're talking it with them and
let's say it is on a show
and you've got viewers who haven't seen
them
this person before but you know they're
going to say the same thing it's exactly
the same thing and it's and it's
something that's that's really obnoxious
and they're going to say it in the same
obnoxious way you know
um great example of a show that was kind
of like that morton downey jr that that
i
i grew up with when i was a kid it was
this this late night show and this guy
would like bring on
all these people to have arguments with
each other and he'd talk really mean to
them as well
and eventually he got in trouble because
he he faked getting
beaten up by by nazis and so that was
the end of his show
but he would bring people on knowing
that exactly what they were going to say
that's why he brought them on he was to
try to get ratings
i kind of think that's the wrong thing
to do in most
in most debates what do you think about
so you got the scenario of
you're talking with this person and you
know what they're going to say do you
owe them another hearing of the same
endless thing so the question is is that
the only thing they're going to say
because it kind of like reminds me of
that oh
the roman center that like would talk
about um the sewers and then it'd always
end
with you know death to the carthaginians
yeah the car
was destroyed yeah yeah um you would
talk about other things but like that
was a stick you'd always
like come back to it is is this is it
solely that or are they talking about
other things as well well that's a good
question
so imagine that no matter what the
conversation is
sooner or later they're going to bring
it back to their their
as we call a hobby horse you know this
this thing that they're obsessed with
okay so i guess
if i was just having a like a 101 or a
small conversation with him
then eventually i won't have the
conversation because we've already had
that conversation over and over and i
feel like there's nothing more
to go about but there's definitely a
difference within
uh if you're having a conversation or if
you're having a debate in front of
viewers and
um and i think that there is um as long
as they're
not just trying to goad you as i talked
about in my previous example
um but they are presenting an issue that
is their hobby horse
that if you feel like that is a a a bad
position then you now have the ability
and an
opportunity to uh have a
reasoned argument about against that
position and now
you are uh kind of counteracting his
hobby horse to the audience as long as
you can
uh you know provide a good argument
against it yeah so there it's it's sort
of like you know
the marketplace of ideas you know
conception where the good arguments
drive out the bad arguments
it only works if we actually do engage
in
in conflict with each other debate or
however you want to frame it
so long as there's there's alternatives
being provided and
that's that's more or less i think what
mill had in mind in thinking that we
should
not just not censor most ideas in their
expression but not even censor
intemperate as he called it expressions
of those ideas you know people being
jerks as they're
they're enunciating them
so uh you had uh an article here on our
notes about
uh gracia and harisia
uh would you give us a little rundown of
that yeah so there's this really nice
piece
in the atlantic by theresa bajan i think
is how her name is pronounced
and she was what's very helpful about it
is she says listen freedom of speech
doesn't just mean one
thing as a matter of fact in ancient
athens they had two different words for
it that denoted two different
aspects of what we often blur together
as
freedom of speech so they had issagoria
and isagoria comes from this word esos
which means same or or equal
and then parasia and parasia
is we do sometimes translate as
frankness of
speech so you may see it in in greek
texts
uh talked about that way so issagoria
was an equal right to participate in
public debate meaning that
it's sort of like when you go to a town
hall you know so long as you
haven't managed to get yourself kicked
out if you want to go to the mic
and ask a question you can ask a
question right they may not
actually you might not like the answer
you get but you at least get to say
say your piece parasia is
being able to say what you want to when
you want to
and to whoever you want to so those are
two different things and
you know in a way parasia is
think of it as like trumping isagoria
and what she was pointing out i think
this is quite helpful is that
sometimes some of the people talking
about freedom of speech have in mind
that everybody gets to actually express
themselves
sometimes they just mean everybody or at
least some people get to say whatever
they want to whoever they want and
without consequence
that's the other part that goes along
with it right yeah yeah being able to
uh be a jerk if you want to verbally
and i i think there's there's um some
real tensions here because
let's say i get up and i'm a person who
can talk for a long time right people
will sometimes
uh have me in to give a talk and they're
like hey can you talk about this and
i'll be like yeah i can talk about that
for half an hour you know
or an hour if you want me to and you
know if i do that
and i and i'm not being attentive to
anybody else now when i talk i'm
actually usually engaging with the
audience and asking them questions
and getting them you know involved
because i i like i like to do that
but man some people will just talk at
you i mean we've had some university
lectures like that right
uh i don't know maybe when maybe you
didn't when you were
a student but i had some who would just
talk
never never like you know asked a
question
or engaged us in discussion well that's
not fair
right that's them getting to have
freedom of speech and that's
freedom for all the rest of us just to
sit and listen
and not get to participate and um you
know so isa goria
would say no everybody has to have a
chance to talk if they want to
and so if you think about how freedom of
speech works out in real life
it's not often isagoric you know
the boss brings you in and says oh i
want uh
everybody to give their ideas there's no
there's no bad ideas we're just
brainstorming
and quickly it you know you realize that
not everybody's ideas are welcome
and some people won't get a chance to
talk you know
um there's you know there's some cases
where it doesn't make sense for
everybody to talk if you go to a rock
concert
um that is not an issagoric sort of
thing right
you're there to hear the band and even
though they ask you how's everyone doing
tonight they're not gonna like
hand the mic around and like each well
i'm doing pretty good you know oh i just
got off of work
you'd never have the concert right
so there's some cases where we don't
want that but i think in a lot of cases
the way some people practice paracea
it makes it impossible for there to be
isagoria
and you know if you think about the the
extended mouthpiece that a lot of people
have because of how many
followers they have or how much money
they have or
having political power or being in a
privileged class or something like that
they drown out a lot of other people's
voices
and so like it kind of reminds me like
uh the agora and where people would
gather in athens was the marketplace and
they would also
interact there and i wonder if that is
uh the root of why we call it the
marketplace of ideas
oh as a etymological term
yeah you know i don't know um that
that's actually a great question i'm
sure there is probably something out
there
specifically on that i mean i know that
socrates
and diogenes the cynic engage in a lot
of discussion with people in the
marketplace but i don't know that
everybody in the marketplace was always
happy to have them
bothering them in the market well they
eventually
killed socrates so i'd say you're onto
something there for that
yeah yeah that's true what is the
the the basis of virtue oh
i don't know so well he made people look
bad
right i mean that's that's the story
that's given
about his older accusers he asks them
questions so he's using his his
capacity to speak and he's putting them
on the spot and then
they get to talk because socrates will
let you talk as much as as you want to
it's just that what you say is going to
look dumb after he's done with you
and people do not like that and then
diogenes cynic would go around and
instead of
engaging in conversation would just uh
blatantly
uh violate the social norms you know
walking around naked and other things
um just to say it's like all of your
stuff is
a social convention and and why are you
so uptight about that
yeah he was he was somebody i don't have
a lot of sympathy for diogenes myself i
don't know about you
i know that he's like a kind of a folk
hero to a lot of people
but he just reminds me of so many
non-conformists that i've known who are
like
so deliberately non-conformist and
you know the cynics call themselves
heralds of the god
you know like they're supposed to be
actually doing
they had a higher calling they're
they're drawing people's attention to
the virtue that they lack but i think a
lot of people that do that sort of stuff
are just you know they're they're uh
playing around they're
and as a matter of fact interestingly in
the ancient world
we see that uh the cynics school they
get made fun of a lot
because apparently some of them were
just doing that they were just being
kind of
jerkish to be jerkish because they could
you know poke at people's
um things and criticize them and kind of
get away with
it it almost makes me think of those
like
idea of the hippie going around like
that guy that maybe like
took this first philosophy of classes
like did i just blow your mind and let
you
say yeah yeah you know the world is all
an illusion man
but getting back to our point here of of
isagoria
and parisia
um is then there was this like
uh evolution of this especially during
the enlightenment
and uh you know you've now um have
people along the lines of
like uh content spinoza and mill
i'm talking about the um
uniting of isigoria and logos or reasons
this is you know that um equality of
debate
and reason uh into kind of an idealized
concept of free speech
um as freedom for reason speech
and rational debate so this is you know
kant um the the freedom to make
public use of one's reason was the
fundamental and equal right of any human
being or citizen
or you know i already quoted on bill
earlier but defending the freedom of
thought and discussion
in the collectivist pursuit of truth or
sorry collective pursuit of truth
yeah and i think that there was a sense
that they had that
most people at least would be carrying
this sort of stuff out
in good faith genuinely trying to
engage in discussion that was supposed
to advance
some values right not not just being
being
mean to people or or engaging in
in other things that that indulge our
worst
parts and and i think that they were
probably unrealistic
in that assumption that these would
result in actual honest debate or what
yeah i
i think that well they're wrong about
that and i also think that they didn't
they didn't really grasp how easily
debates could be taken over
by all sorts of other things that
allowed some people to have a big
mouthpiece and other people
just to get kind of pushed to the side
you know
this was an ideal that they were
espousing and it gets used
as an ideal like it's abused as an ideal
by people who
are are hiding behind it in order to
say that they should be able to say
whatever they want and they shouldn't
have any consequences of other people
like you know
not liking it or or responding to them
in kind
um so do you think the ideal itself is
flawed or just the usage
of the ideal that's a good question i
mean i
i think that the ideal it's not that
it's
simply flawed it's that it's inadequate
it's that it doesn't provide you with
enough you need to have
there's there's two sides to this one is
that
you've got something kind of similar to
the free rider problem
right with with uh any sort of public
utility of commons
yeah and so you've got to find some way
to deal with that
but i think in order to make it work you
also need to have some people
who genuinely are trying to make the
discourse better
and so this is where again i think it's
useful to talk less about
rights and more about responsibilities
and what is it to be
a responsible person with your speech
and i think part of that is accepting
responsibility for what you say socrates
is a prime example there right
he he did in fact um allow them to
execute him which
involved him actually drinking the
poison
i'm not saying he hadn't out he could
have gone and uh lived at what a
friend's villa
yeah exactly credo had bribed the guards
and was like hey come on let's get the
hell out of here
uh they don't like you they treated you
unfairly and socrates
well let's consider this and by the end
of it uh
he's not going anywhere so that's part
of it
i think he also you know being
responsible would mean taking
responsibility for being
well informed um maybe there's a duty
if you you know at least in certain
discussions like if you're going to talk
about covid19
you need to have actually like done some
basic research and that doesn't
research is not watching a single
youtube video or something like that
it's it's
you know learning about what public
health is and
um you know also making a little basic
skepticism so you know how to actually
find good
information that's important too what we
call information literacy
you know um and then i think not every
debate needs to be hashed out at every
time so there's a prudence about what
we're going to talk about at what time
there's some topics that we probably
shouldn't talk about with uh
certain people or with with children um
if we're gonna treat things that are um
controversial it's it's it's you know
there's there's good ways to do that and
there's bad ways to do that there's ways
that are gonna create more conflict
uh and then there's ways that are going
to try to create uh bridges
and then you know communicating with
other people in good faith that's really
important
um i think that's part of being a
responsible
yeah an honest interlocutor not just
trying to like
you know get something out of it
yourself um
what else do you think needs to go into
that and just to
you know interlocutor we said it several
times we want to make sure that we
define that term and not interlock it or
someone is on
debating in good faith um that you're
uh trying to honestly give your opinion
and and work out the truth of something
though the the idea is not to win the
argument but to
come to a a better understanding through
argument
yeah and and so like
part of this is also you should you know
if you're gonna actually engage in
argument you should have at least a
passing understanding
of what fallacious reasoning is and some
of the like
the basic ones and if you know what
fallacious reasoning is
it doesn't mean that you're bad or wrong
for
making these arguments but that uh they
are bad arguments they're
they're arguments uh not bad arguments
but arguments that will not always
result in true answers
yeah they often lead us away from the
truth right as a way yeah
um and and you can come to the right
conclusion for
wrong reasons the reason and why we want
to have non-fallacious arguments is we
want arguments that will
always bring us to true answers if we
argue them
correctly and also it's not something
that is like
bad about you if you happen to fall into
these that if someone calls you out on
that argument
it's like oh i've now been given the
ability to
think and reason about this in a better
way to find a better argument
yeah that's that's where a lot of people
have
quite a a hard time right myself
included
actually i'll i'll certainly cop to that
nobody really likes to hear that you're
wrong in the way that you've thought
something out
but it does you know if you can actually
be open to it
then you can improve what you're
you're thinking and not just in terms of
like you know theoretical matters but
very practical matters you know if you
think that
the way to interact with people is
here's a prime example my dad used to
tease us a lot when we were kids
and it was in part because he was kind
of immature that way i mean he died when
he was
only 36 so obviously he didn't get much
of a chance to to develop
and he probably got that idea from his
dad that that's the way to show love to
people
it would drive us nuts you know we
didn't like it but both of us kids
me and my sister picked it up and it
took a long time
to break out of that and i found myself
doing that
even with my kids and then people and i
wasn't the one who was like oh greg
you're really doing the wrong thing was
other people having to say
listen dummy you're doing the same thing
that you say you don't like right
nobody likes to get called out on that
sort of thing but
when it comes to communicating with
other people we do need to
you know we do need to take the raw
material that we are with its jagged
edges
and refine it a bit
once in the future we'll all be nice
rounded corners like all those iphones
[Laughter]
yeah we'd all have to come out of some
factory
probably for that yeah or let's go to
you know a nice rounded stone in the
ocean that's a lot more organic
true yeah but it takes a lot longer
right
mm-hmm and if you're good
if you have motion sickness that's not
going to work for you though
so what's our practice this week greg
so we can just call it prudence in use
of speech and i think
this could be this is something that
does come out of virtue ethics
but doesn't necessarily have to be tied
to any particular school
so when you're tempted to wade into some
discussion where you think that people
are getting things wrong or using their
freedom of speech wrongly
consider just like take a pause and
consider is this the place where i
myself need to take a stand is this the
right thing for me to do
maybe it is and if it is well then go
ahead and do that you know
if you're the only person who can speak
up for the person who's
say being bullied and you know you might
actually not just speak up with them you
might talk to the people who are
standing on the side and say hey
aren't you going to do anything about
this you know this is wrong
not just confront the bully if that's
the case then go ahead and do that
but in a lot of cases i think we find
that it's not it's not the the right
time
or we don't have to be the one who's the
you know the defender of all
values or whatever it is and then what
we can do
instead of just saying okay i'm going to
withdraw from this and like go and eat
chips and do nothing
we can deliberately use our capacity
for speech productively elsewhere you
know if we if we really think that we
need to be involved
in standing up for something there's
plenty of things we can stand up for
we have all sorts of opportunities now
that we have you know
we all live in the internet um you could
just do a google search
and find something you could stand up
for if it's you know the rights of uh
animals i'm sure there's plenty of
places you could go
to to do that if it's um i don't know
saying that uh we should uh
celebrate a particular holiday or not
celebrate a particular holiday there's
places you can go for that we could come
up with endless examples
so that's that's the basic idea it's
it's an extension of the virtue of
prudence
you know using the resources that we
have rightly
it kind of it comes immediately to mind
like
the jains in which at least the most
devout of them will wear a veils over
their faces in order to make sure
they're not even
inhaling small insects because they they
have this incredible
uh reverence for all living
things and and will sweep the street in
front of them and you know
some people only do this at like high
holidays but there are definitely jane
monks who will
do this at a very almost constant level
and if you're
gonna go out and like protest and say
everyone needs to do exactly what the
jane's the most about jane's are doing
all the time
because i have this ideal of that
anything that
might um be able to feel pain
that or or is alive has a fundamental
uh right to life and that they uh
that none of our actions should ever
even
accidentally harm them then i don't
think you're gonna get a lot of people
to actually
buy onto your campaign no that's that's
a very tough one
the jains are probably that's one of the
most difficult spiritual paths just in
that extent to follow and and you when
you read i
you know i used to teach about them and
when i taught world religion classes and
i read some giant scriptures and
man the stuff that the renunciants do is
intense
you know um but coming but coming back
to this i mean that's that's very far
removed from where we are
you know there might actually there
might be
some point to people getting their
feelings hurt some of the time
it could lead to useful um
confrontations you know reconsiderations
of their own position i know i benefited
quite a bit
even though i didn't realize it at the
time from people telling me that i was
wrong and being a jerk
um so you know but
but it can be done in different ways you
know this is where we can
again come to the responsibility of
speech
just because we can say something
doesn't mean that we automatically
should say it or we should say it in the
way that we want to say it
we should probably think about the other
person
and there's there's a lot of cases where
perhaps even the people who are being
jerks
we don't have to necessarily fight fire
with fire
you know i wonder is there it seems like
there could be a a meeting in the middle
somewhere i don't know if
that should be like 80 20 or something
um
but of like there are certain things
that i guess
you can't control and you can't control
the other people's actions around you
and their speech and so there's you know
there's definitely things that are very
rude and and socially inappropriate
um but there's also things that are just
kind of annoying and
that does not hit the same level of
offense as other things
right probably be aware of that and try
to modulate to what is
actually the things that are beyond the
pale i mean when we're calling things
out for example
yeah or or when someone is talking to
you and saying like oh you
i didn't enjoy
okay yeah that makes good sense well i
see that we're
we're just about at the end of our
time so we've got
the outgoing words that are commonly
attributed to mark
wayne probably are much older in its
original formation
but never argue with an idiot he'll drag
you down to his level
and he'll be with experience
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
you